الرئيس الفرنسي تحدث عن مساله تسليم
المقاتله الى كييف واشار الى ان الامر لا
يتطابق مع احتياجات اليوم وبالنسبه له
الاولويه هي تقديم المعدات الاكثر فائده
لا يمكن تحت اي ظرف تسليم طائرات مقاتله
لاوكرانيا في الاسابيع المقبله نظرا لوجود
جدول زمني لتسليم الطائرات لم يتدرب عليها
الطيارون الاوكرانيون وهذا لا يخضع
للمساومه لا استبعد شيئا لكن هذا لا
يتطابق مع احتياجات اليوم
الرئيس الاوكراني وبعد استقبال الاتحاد
الاوروبي له بحفاوه عائله تسريع امداد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه وخلال جولته الاوروبيه
يومي الاربعاء والخميس اصر زيلينسكي على
ان بلاده بحاجه الى مقاتله لانهاء الحرب
التي تقودها روسيا في بلاده وتاتي تصريحات
الرئيس الفرنسي في سياق تصريحات اخرى
للقاده الاوروبيين بدت اكثر ترددا بشان
المطلب الاوكراني وسبب يعود لخشيتها من
تداعيات هذه الخطوه التي قد تعتبرها موسكو
تصعيدا واستفزازا المانيا لم تتطرق الى
مساله تزويد كيف بالطائرات المقاتله
واكتفى مستشرها بالتعبير عن الدعم وصف
علاقته ببرلين بانها تشبه الامواج في
حركتها صعودا وهبوطا وذلك في مقابله مع
صحيفه الالمانيه وقال انه مطر باستمرار
لاقناع المستشار الالماني بمساعده
اوكرانيا من اجل اوروبا اليوم تشعر بالقلق
الكبير بشان ما تطلق عليه بالنجاحات
العسكريه الاخيره التي حققتها موسكو في
الدومباس
وتخشى هجوما كبيرا في الاسابيع المقبله